-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And now if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
According to a new poll,
President Biden would defeat
former president Trump
in a hypothetical 2024
election rematch by 8 points.
Pretty bad,
but not as defeated as I feel
hearing about that poll.
Can we not do this yet?
[ Laughter ]
It's January.
The only thing I want to hear
less than a presidential poll
is a Christmas carol.
[ Laughter ]
Secretary of State Tony Blinken
sent a cable to all embassies
yesterday
directing staff to switch from
Times New Roman font to Calibri,
while President Biden will
continue to speak in Wingdings.
[ Laughter ]
Georgia congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
was assigned yesterday
to the House Committee
on Homeland Security.
Well, she does seem
to know about attacks
before they happen.
[ Laughter ]
The Treasury Department
said that tomorrow,
it will begin using
extraordinary measures
to keep the federal government
running,
which explains
this new eBay listing.
[ Laughter ]
I think they made a terrible
mistake adding free shipping.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
Republican congressman
George Santos
allegedly stole $3,000
from a GoFundMe campaign
for a dying service dog that
belonged to a disabled veteran,
and then get this, he used
the money to buy dog poison.
[ Audience groans ]
Now, again,
halfway through that joke,
I started thinking, "How do I
think this is going to go?"
[ Laughter ]
It's a bad joke,
but is it as bad...
as what he did?
[ Laughter ]
Still seems like you guys
might think it's a tie.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like
I'm Congress material.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department
this week confirmed --
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department this week
confirmed a new set of policies
that incentivizes companies
to report wrongdoing
in exchange for
deferred prosecution,
which could prevent us
from seeing
over a dozen new limited series.
[ Laughter ]
Should we unplug it
and plug it back in?
[ Laughter ]
A boy in Maine recently
broke a Guinness world record
by building a nearly
12,000-piece LEGO set
in just over nine hours, much
to the chagrin of his parents.
"That was supposed to
take you all year!"
[ Laughter ]
New York's Port Authority
announced yesterday
that it will close
the New Jersey-bound tube
of the Holland Tunnel next month
for construction.
So if you need to go
to New Jersey,
I have even more bad news.
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in Washington State
are looking for a man
who allegedly tried
to kidnap a barista
by pulling them through
the drive-through window.
Despite the best efforts
of police,
the suspect remains at venti.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
I stand by it.
Today was
National Thesaurus Day.
It was, yeah, good.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, the world's oldest
known person, a French nun,
has reportedly died
at the age of 118.
And I got to say,
I'd feel pretty bad
if I was the one who bought her
that skateboard.
[ Laughter ]
What happened to us?
Well, to be fair,
this is only our fourth show.
1,389?
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
Now you're going to tell me
it's bad luck
to make fun
of a dead French nun.
[ Laughter ]
Is that her?
Why did we have to
put her picture up?
[ Laughter ]
Oh, good.
Look, I don't want
to blame this on you guys.
You've done nothing wrong.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that was the monologue.
I don't know. Yeah.
We got a great show
for you tonight.